there's some sort of veil being lifted
on our monetary system
where compared to right now our monetary
system is
managed by the either the federal
reserve or the central bank the united
states government
which is essentially the the standard of
the world um
is it because are people interested in
this because this is democratizing the
money
and sharing it like both transparently
and theoretically eventually equally
around the world is that the driver here
or is it really like uh
the other piece is like
anti-establishment the world is ending
the dollar is going to fail
middle finger to the world by bitcoin to
the moon i think it's a combination of
those things and for everyone who enters
it's it's a little bit different but i
do think that this is a populist
movement in some ways but it's a healthy
form of populism because it's not saying
we're going to burn down the old system
it's that it's saying we're going to opt
out we're going to build this new
awesome system
and this new system this new money
system this new financial system
is going to be based on credibly neutral
protocols right so if you think about
the
the the monetary policy of the us um
and when individuals think about that
well what is that controlled by it's
called
controlled by jerome powell and a small
group of individuals
right and they're trying their best
i'm sure right but do they always get it
right no they don't always get it right
and do they have undue control
and have they over the past you know 10
to 20 years
printed money more in favor of like the
establishment in the banking system this
is back to the cantillon
cantillian effect that we were talking
about earlier where where this money
printing
is not going to average citizens in the
us
it's going to bankers and people who
hold assets that's why if you want to
play the
monetary game in the united states you
can't just hold dollars
in a savings account anymore right like
you're not making any money that way you
have to play the game you have to buy
assets you have to invest
and so people are saying well should a
small group of
individuals in washington be able to
uh to to turn the dials
on the money system what happens if they
become corrupt and so this is a
ground-up movement
to say no we want to build our money
system and by the way not just central
banking but also commercial banking
on credibly neutral protocols where um
you know the the that can't be biased
that can't be corrupted
uh and so this is this is kind of a
reaction to some of the the wealth
inequality that we've seen this is a
reaction to censorship this is a
reaction to
um you know hedge fund managers calling
the the owners of robin hood and saying
stop trading gamestop right it's a
reaction to all of these things
and this is crypto's moment this is
crypto's decade i think this is why this
is an important movement for us
let me ask though because i i totally
understand the dynamic of like
the kind of establishment has been
rigging the system
and making the rules and setting rules
for far too long and therefore sort of
the only people who have been benefiting
from the rules
but there is a movement really on the
left in the united states this like
almost modern
monetary theory camp that says look if
we can kind of print money
limitlessly right we could in theory
print money and give it directly to
people
right and like print money for for a ubi
or something like that
what concerns me about
when we look at the future of bitcoin
and these sort of um
limited currencies is is sort of what
the issue was maybe with the gold
standard which is there is a finite
amount of it
and are we going to end up in a world
where once again you have a finite
resource and it's all pooling to
elites and there's no more that can be
created
how do you respond to that or what are
people thinking about that
so i think that is a really insightful
comment carly like i think you hit the
nail on the head and
there there is um there are different
like camps and communities inside of of
cryptocurrency so there's this strong
austrian know economic uh bent
that would hate everything that you just
said about modern monetary theory i may
be in that camp for what it's worth
okay well so like there's that camp and
they say like no government shouldn't
print money
right we should we should have a
credibly neutral standard something like
a gold standard right
and that should come from from
cryptocurrency um but to your point
well what what's what's the response
when you say well that's just going to
lead to
an unequal system in the future where
people who bought in bitcoin early or
whatever crypto
early like they end up being the the
elites and the new bankers right so
that's one group in crypto
but there's another group in crypto
because it's a very you know
wide camp that thinks that well we we
have
been uh printing money and essentially
we've we've been giving out ubi
we've been giving out ubi for the last
like 20 years
but we've we've been giving it to the
wealthy right so
so maybe what we need is a ubi system
um for for um everyone else the citizens
right this is kind of andrew yang's
platform
and well with cryptocurrency with with
uh systems like ethereum
this makes a a great path for
distributing that money
right so like i don't know but getting a
check
from the irs or whoever issued it that
you know for
for um uh covid you know stimulus
basically that was a very long process
what if you could just
hit a button and a digital currency from
issued by the central banks in the us
just appeared in your wallet
right so like so like this is the type
of innovation we could tap into and
there's a whole side of the crypto
community that's like
hey you know uh we don't think that
bottom
money like a bitcoin or an ether should
be outlawed
right we think that people should have
that option but we also think that that
central banks
should play a role in this and they
should promote
better distribution of their money
through things like ubi and
cryptocurrency can be
and you know can be sort of a conduit in
a network to make that more efficient
um so you'll find both both sides of the
camp uh
represented in the in the crypto
community i think i believe it's bitcoin
in particular
they have done some work on regulation
they have
been working with governments to prevent
the money laundering piece of this
because the the down the dark side of
cryptocurrency is that
if it's completely anonymous really like
you can't follow the money anymore
and you end up in some really really
really dark places um
so talk to me a bit about where we are
today on
what's called the regulation of this or
not in regulation like how governments
have been working with the crypto
currency community
or not working with them we're not
working yeah we are afraid of them
so that so the crypto community the
internet community has always talked
about government as kind of the final
boss right it's like you pop its head up
and shut it down the internet right so
much
so um that's been an ongoing meme and i
i would just say that that's been an
ongoing mean since since kind of the
birth of
of bitcoin but um what i would say is
the the regulatory regime in the us
and in most countries around the world
has actually been surprisingly friendly
to crypto
um which is which is which is great uh
so
you know the banks are now bank charters
can now custody
crypto assets in the u.s uh the
commodities
the cftc the commodities future exchange
has just
said that bitcoin is a commodity so it
can be regulated that way and so is
ether
a commodity there's been no move to
really
outlaw cryptocurrencies i think par part
of the reason for this and and by the
way
on the comment about sort of uh you know
anonymous cash and the hazards of that
well i mean the the biggest anonymous
cash and money laundering actually
happens with like dollars
right it's actually if you want to
launder if you want to launder money
cash is easier yeah it's way easier like
there's fiat on ramps to crypto
it's it's open but it's not completely
private
in in bitcoin or in ethereum so if you
want to launder money
like don't do this guys but like cash is
the way to do it benjamin's that's where
briefcase is flowing breaking bad i know
your time i'm just you know
so so um so anyway it's it's actually
not a good tool for
learning money and i think what's what's
happening is governments are realizing
that there are
far more wins uh than than losses with
the adoption of crypto there's going to
be a whole new kind of
where's the crypto silicon valley going
to be located is that going to be in the
jurisdiction of the u.s or is it going
to be another country are we going to
like what about uh distribution of
central bank digital currencies well
those should happen on public networks
like like ethereum so
there are all of these efficiency wins
that governments have similar to the
early internet
like the early internet it's it's a
little bit scary to say we've got this
communication protocol
anyone in the world can spin up a
website and you know start projecting
whatever ideas they have that's a little
bit scary for governments right
but the wins uh in adopting that
protocol the protocol of the internet
far outweighed the losses and so
everybody did it and i think that's
that's what's happening with governments
around the world is they're all adopting
this technology for the wins
i'm so excited to watch prime ministers
and global leaders talk about dodge coin
or
whatever dreams we whip up um
it's gonna be exciting and i i believe
if you do not understand this you're
unfit to lead
because this same community just wiped
out wall street for about a week
um like this is real and it's
frustrating to watch leaders
pretend they don't understand it or
think it's like a weird internet culture
thing
on the other hand is there a certain
advantage again i worry about
these kinds of technologies ultimately
being co-opted by sort of these elite
institutions and
undermining the very sort of advantages
they provide which is this like
democratization effect right and so is
there a certain advantage
that call it the internet right now has
in that a lot of leaders don't
necessarily fully understand this and it
kind of gives us an opportunity to make
sure it sort of
is implemented democratically you know
before you know before sort of these
column elite institutions or
establishment institutions are able to
really kind of co-opt them and
manipulate them to their own gains
totally i think the birth story
like we talked about cryptos it almost
had an immaculate conception
because all along the establishment has
has
has shunned it right it's like oh it's
too volatile to be a money
right for like the the boom and bust
cycles like of course every time they
said this is like a
you know a a a tulips kind of like fad
and it's all going to
to fade out every single cycle they said
this and so
uh what's happened is people have been
the first to adopt it
developers internet natives have been
the first to adopt it i think it would
be far less interesting
if in like year one of bitcoin the us
government just bought all the bitcoin
right and that's not going to distribute
cryptocurrency to the people
the other thing i'll say to you is like
one concern i have
being in cryptocurrency is back to
exactly what you said carly which is
like
we have to make sure that we're not just
creating a new crypto system
with like bitcoin as the gold standard
and we get a new set of bankers but
they're still bankers right
this is why ethereum is so important
this is why this idea of decentralized
finance is important because
bitcoin just gives you sort of a money
but that that money
is often custodied in this new set of
banks called crypto banks these are the
coin bases and gemini's of the world
with ethereum what what you get is the
ability to actually do the banking
yourself in a self-sovereign way it
creates like banks
as proto as protocols on top of it so
that's sort of we can get into what it
means to to go bankless
but that's sort of what what we're
talking about going bankless means
actually replacing the banks wholesale
not creating a new set of banks
replacing the banks with these credibly
neutral protocols and this is the idea
of open finance or
decentralized finance if you've heard
those terms
[Music]
you